do you ever just play dark souls and
think to yourself what is the deal with
dark souls but seriously unlike most
RPGs that are bursting at the seams with
endless codex entries and NPCs that just
won't shut up dark souls is rather
restrained in its storytelling like the
game itself at each stuff out in dribs
and drabs and most of the time you have
to connect the dots yourself so it all
makes sense and even then this various
ways that the story and characters can
be interpreted but ain't nobody got time
for that regardless of looking and
sounding fast as hell dark souls is
steeped in law and as Dark Souls 3 is
out early next year here's my quick
start guide to it all ok so in Dark
Souls lore there are three ages well
technically there's two because the
third is bad and you try and stop it
from happening or not don't worry this
will all make sense later let's start
with the age of the Ancients admittedly
it was a bit boring everything was gray
there were no humans to mess stuff up
and the everlasting dragons ruled the
roost it was dark but then there was
light the first flame seemed to come out
of nowhere Gwyn the Lord of sunlight did
some poking around and found some
immensely powerful Lord stones within it
he gifted those to the witch of izalith
gravelord nito and the furtive pygmy
giving them the powers of God's
naturally a great war was started
between the four lords and the
everlasting dragons for control of the
world one dragon the mortals Seath the
scaleless defected against his own kind
to fight for the Lord's but that wasn't
out of the kindness of his scale-free
heart he coveted a treasure that would
make him immortal because dragons and
their treasure am i right anyway the
Lord's one the Dragons lost this ushered
in the age of fire an era of great
growth and prosperity Gwyn the witch and
nieto were like gods no one really knows
what the pygmy was up to but it's
greatly inferred that his soul was what
gave life to humanity some show he was
keeping busy and everyone was as happy
as I guess they could be in the souls
universe until and there's always an
until the first flame started to
diminish and the Lord cells began to
weaken heralding the third age the age
of dark everyone
understandably freaked out a little bit
the witch tried to recreate the first
flame using magic which failed and ended
up killing her children and corrupting
her so that she became the mother of all
demons a plus for effort F for execution
Gwyn ends sacrificing himself to
rekindle the first flame by linking his
cell to it which works but has the
unfortunate side effect of creating the
undead cursed where the afflicted are
stuck in a loop of death and rebirth
which hey is where you come in in Dark
Souls you're the chosen undead you get
to depose these Lords with swear words
and sweaty controllers and then you're
presented with a choice if you want to
you can sacrifice yourself to the first
flame at the end to delay the age of
dark again oh you can just extinguish
the flame and become the Dark Lord like
Voldemort but with a nose and all that
undead stuff is key in Dark Souls 2
where you're trying to rid yourself of
the undead curse but there's no concrete
word on whether Dark Souls 2 or even the
upcoming three are direct sequels or if
they're just said in the same universe
there's just mere speculation Oh
Miyazaki what are we gonna do with you
that's over this week I'm back again
next week with some more in two minutes
don't forget I'm on twitter at Lucy
James games and I'll see you next time